[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut que ça se sache
c'est ce que je me suis dit
instinctivement le jour où j'ai su que
je voulais devenir journaliste j'avais 9
ans autant vous dire que je savais pas
vraiment qu'est ce qu'ils devaient
savoir ni dans quel but et pourtant
cette phrase et ses variantes gelé
répété à maintes reprises depuis
nous devons prendre conscience ça a déjà
dû vous arrivez à vous aussi vous
découvrez quelque chose dans les médias
ou à l'occasion d'une conférence vous
écouter un documentaire ou lisez le
portrait d'une personne inspirante et
vous ne pouvez pas vous empêcher de
penser que cette information mérite
d'être partagée
il faut que ça se sache progressivement
j'ai aussi compris pourquoi il me
semblait si nécessaire de partager un
fait un témoignage une histoire j'ai
réalisé que je ne peux tout simplement
pas lutter contre un problème dont je ne
connais pas l'existence j'ai compris que
l'information et transformatrices j'ai
pris conscience du pouvoir éducatif est
émancipateur des récits ce qui nous
inspire autant que ceux qui nous invite
à repenser nos façons de voir et de
faire les choses et c'est ce que je vis
depuis 2014
en tant que co rédactrice en chef de
l'express the world particulièrement
depuis 2016 année où nous avons lancé le
premier numéro de notre magazine annuel
à destination des femmes
à diversité sexuelle une publication
imprimée entièrement bilingue témoin de
son temps à la croisée du média
d'information et de l'oeuvre d'art notre
intention était somme toute assez simple
pour ne pas dire si évidemment
indispensable nous voulions faire
entendre nos voix faire rayonner les
talents les initiatives les expériences
des communautés lesbienne visibilité
représentativité collégialité nos
histoires étaient absentes des discours
publics médiatique sociaux et même
communautaire pas ces femmes pour se
voir raconté dans la presse féminine
moins visible que les hommes gays au
sein de la communauté lgbt qu plus ça a
commencé comme ça en tant que minorité
dans la minorité alors pour être
politiquement correct on dirait la
diversité au sein de la diversité
nous voulions prendre place à part
entière dans les conversations
le problème c'est que les communautés
lesbiennes ne sont pas sont loin en fait
de former un ensemble monolithique et
homogène 12 usage du pluriel les
communautés à l'image de la diversité
des identités des membres qui les
composent
prenez moi par exemple à l'évidence
j'appartiens à la majorité privilégié
des femmes blanches éduqué je suis aussi
franco canadienne dans la trentaine
lesbiennes européenne convaincue fille
d'une pieds noirs d'algérie et d'un
français de métropole
ce rennais d'une personne en situation
de handicap
j'ai été élevé en créole à la réunion
une des îles les plus métissés au monde
où l'on danse le zouk le séga le maloya
j étais exposé à plusieurs traditions de
religion mono et polythéistes est encore
aujourd'hui la cuisine réunionnaise est
celle qui affole le plus mes papilles et
que je sais régulièrement mes invités
j'ai fréquenté l'université des deux
côtés de l'atlantique et mon cercle
d'amis cumule plus de dix nationalités
je suis donc autant le produit de mon
héritage culturel et familial que des
rencontres et des événements qui
ponctuent ma vie selon la situation et
le contexte je fais tantôt partie de la
majorité
tantôt de la minorité je me suis
construite dans l'altérité parfois
conformément parfois en réaction aux
normes établies
j'ai déjà caché des partis deux mois
pour tenter de m'intégrer un petit peu
mieux
j'ai aussi revendiqué des idées des
valeurs qui me sont chères
j'ai lu écouté persister et changer
d'avis
bref mon apparence et ma vie quotidienne
ne reflète que partiellement mon
sentiment d'appartenance et la multitude
d'influencés auquel je m'identifie c'est
pour ça que aussi éloignées soit elle de
ma réalité
chacune des histoires qui ont été
racontées dans le magazine est lesté w
depuis trois ans est venue résonné en
moi d'une façon ou d'une autre
nombreux sont les témoignages qui sont
venus toucher ne serait-ce qu'une petite
partie de moi même qui m'ont aidé à
apaiser mon sentiment de solitude et ont
réveillé une réflexion au sein de
l'équipe est restée w
comme de nombreuses militantes avant
nous notre ambition est d'améliorer
notre condition alors notre premier
réflexe a été de mettre de l'avant nos
points communs valoriser ce qui nous
rassemble
ce qui fait consensus et faire front
contre ce que nous identifions comme une
menace immédiate l'homophobie le
patriarcat l'hétéro centrisme pour ne
citer que celles là et pourtant c'est
dans nos différences quant à trouver le
plus de richesses et où on a trouvé les
plus grands enseignements
parce qu'il existe plusieurs minorités
dans la diversité une infinité de
diversité dans la minorité
et oui figurez vous qu'une femme peut
aussi être noir et handicapées et
musulmane qu'une lesbienne peut aussi
être trans et autochtones qu'une arabe
ou une asiatique peut aussi être
chrétienne est jeune et
mais vous comprenez le concept les
sociologues parlent incident d'inter
sectional it et pour désigner le fait
qu'un même individu peut subir
simultanément plusieurs discrimination
de classe de race de sexe de handicap
d'identité et d'orientation sexuelle
mais aussi linguistiques religieuses
générationnel par exemple et aucune
inégalité n'est plus supportable qu'une
autre chaque expérience d'exclusion et
d'injustice est impactante alors
imaginez quand on les cumuls du fait des
diverses composantes de nos identités
on existe sans arrêt d'un côté ou de
l'autre d'un rapport de domination ont
subi un entrecroisement d'oppression un
empilement de discrimination finalement
autant que nos identités
la menace est multiple et plurielle
finalement une fois qu'on a compris ça
on peut repenser entièrement notre
manière de vivre ensemble mais aussi de
militer de prendre action
le prono x poético le privé est
politique
ce slogan utilisé dans le cadre des
mouvements de libération des femmes à
partir des années 60 à part est plus que
jamais d'actualité
pendant la révolution sociale des années
60 et 70 les mouvements gays féministe
et en faveur des droits civiques ont été
concomitant sans pour autant vraiment
s'associer il existait même au sein des
différents groupes communautaires une
certaine injonction à étouffer ses
particularités identitaire tout ça pour
le bien de la cause et à celles qui
réclamé une meilleure prise en compte de
situations distinctive on répondait
qu'il valait mieux ne pas mélanger les
choses ne pas se détourner de l'objectif
principal c'est comme ça que les femmes
de couleur ont continué à subir du
racisme d'un côté et du sexisme de
l'autre que les femmes homosexuelles ont
été écartés des revendications
féministes et que la lutte contre les
stérilisations forcées des femmes noires
autochtones portoricaine aux états unis
auraient été accusés de porter préjudice
à la cause du droit à l'avortement
fondamentalement l'intention n'a jamais
été malveillantes
elle visait à ne pas brouiller les
revendications à concentrer les énergies
en faveur d'une possible victoire pour
l'intérêt général et isoler les combats
n'a pas empêché d'indéniables avancés
sauf que les acquis demeurent fragiles
et que de nombreuses divisions perdure
encore aujourd'hui en fait cette
approche-là fait peser sur chacun
d'entre nous une certaine pression au
choix comment est ce que je dois me
présenter
qu'est ce qui prime chez moi
à quelle culture ou à quelle nationalité
est ce que je m'identifie le plus est-ce
que je dois orienté ma lutte pour
l'égalité en fonction de mon
appartenance ethnique ou de ma classe
sociale est ce que je dois défendre mon
jean où mon orientation sexuelle
ces questions vous semble être familière
et pourtant les différentes facettes de
nos identités ne cohabitent pas de
manière autonome et hiérarchique
elle forme un tout qu'une seule
appartenance soient touchés et c'est
toute la personne qui vibre écrivait le
franco libanais amin maalouf
en choisissant est-ce que je ne deviens
pas complice involontaire d'un système
profondément élitiste et arbitraire
est-ce que je ne suis pas condamner à
reproduire diverses formes de division
je crois que nous aurions intérêt à
mettre beaucoup plus d'énergie au profit
de la liberté d'être soi tout simplement
s'accepter soi-même et les autres tels
que nous sommes dans toute notre
multiplicité et notre diversité de
nombreuses expériences sont encore un
visibiliser de nombreuses spécificités
sont encore réduites au silence parce
que nous nous auto censure on mais
surtout parce que la société ne valorise
pas toutes les identités de la même
manière et de façon égale et moi j'aime
à croire qu'en révélant et en
réhabilitant nos diversités
nous pouvons changer les choses de
manière durable et structurelles
affirmation revendications inclusion
alors j'ai pas la prétention de savoir
quelle forme devrait idéalement prendre
le militantisme du futur mais je pense
qu'on pourrait au moins commencer par là
nous avons la possibilité d'aller les
unes vers les autres d'aller les uns
vers les autres de réaliser à quel point
nos réalités sont connectés et
interdépendantes
dans ce que nous avons en commun mais
aussi dans ce qui nous distingue
nous devons appréhender les choses de
manière plus transversale saisir chaque
occasion d'en savoir plus sur celles et
ceux que nous avons été que nous sommes
et que nous pouvons être pour trouver
des solutions ensemble pour trouver des
solutions qui n'exclut pas qu'ils ne
généralise pas et qui sont gagnantes
pour tous nous ne devons pas nous ne
pouvons pas attendre d'être directement
impacté pour nous sentir concernés
ce n'est qu'à cette condition que nos
luttes seront complètes mais ce n'est
pas facile
cela implique de prendre conscience de
nos propres privilèges de nous immerger
dans des expériences qui nous sont peu
familière de dépasser certaines de nos
résistances cela suppose de questionner
notre propre rôle d'oppresseurs de
partager l'espace et de poser des
questions qui dérangent mais il se dit
qu aller à la découverte de l'autre
c'est aller à la découverte de soi et
moi j'aime croire que l'inversé est tout
aussi vrai et ça aussi il faudrait que
ça se sache
[Applaudissements]